so we're going to get to the point where
you'll see something of this form and
you'll say
great i know exactly what that is but i
want you to reason through what's going
on
okay now we're going to do another
just like this but unlike this first
example
when we have a go at these you can see i
haven't given you
quite so neat a pair of points right now
i'm going to think about
what equation would i write that would
give me
the perpendicular bisector of these two
points here's my start for you there's
going to be two
moduli that are equal to each other how
will i write it
you want to make the distance to here
and the distance
to here so i want to try the left hand
side for me what should i put in there
[Applause]
how do i algebraically say
the distance from my complex number z
that can move around
and negative i
hmm
[Music]
interesting how do we do it the first
time
i've got a couple examples here right
like here
this is my way of saying the distance
between z
and that spot there negative 1. so if i
want the distance between
z and this spot negative i
how would i write that yeah it'll be z
plus i because what i'm doing is z take
away
negative i that's that's how i find the
distance between two things
so those double negatives are going to
cancel and that gives me this
okay in much the same way that the
double negatives here cancel to give me
z plus one but this is a different set
of points okay
uh what about oh this guy there's going
to be another z
take away here
it's gonna be easier take away this
normally we would just like expand that
out so if you said take away three
take away i i suppose you could also
write that in this
form both of those would be equivalent
wouldn't they okay
now the tricky thing about this you've
probably i hope already got those two
points on your r gain diagram
and you can go ahead right now and just
like you've got a ruler
you can draw the perpendicular bisector
in i'd love you to go and do that
however in this case because the points
aren't so nice
you can't just read off the equation at
least i can't i can't look at it and say
oh i know exactly where that goes even
when you're on a grid
so for that reason we need to think a
little harder about how we can find
this cartesian equation so i'm going to
pause for a minute
let you have a think about how you would
go about that while i make some myself
some more
space and then we're going to try and
tackle this together with a technique we
haven't done from tuesday
let's have a think about this together
and as i sort of wandered around around
a little bit i saw some people making
some starts and others just kind of like
look at that and think
where do i go from here now um there's a
good couple of ways that we can go about
finding the
cartesian equation for the lockers that
satisfies
locus i should say that satisfies this
equation we've got here okay in complex
terms
i can convert this to something that's
just x's and y's
i'm going to talk through method one and
then i'm going to actually do method two
right
method one is you can say oh i've i've
seen something like this before
modulus equals modulus i'm familiar with
the kind of shape that should emerge
from that it's the one we did in the
first example
this should be a perpendicular bisector
right
so when you then look at your argon
diagram you can say
this is the interval that i need to be
perpendicular to so therefore
if i just find this gradient the
perpendicular gradient to that will be
the
negative reciprocal right and then you
can just find out whatever that is
you'll get a gradient
then you also need to find out to bisect
this like i don't just want to be
perpendicular anywhere i've got to be
perpendicular and through
that spot right there right the midpoint
so if you can find the midpoint there
it's not too hard in this case right
find the midpoint then you can just go
from a gradient and a point set of
coordinates you can just go
point gradient form and that'll be fine
okay so that's great
if you already know in advance what kind
of shape this should provide for you
and you can say i know the features that
will define that
that's handy if you already know where
you're going
but what if you do not right if you're
like if you meet some other thing it
looks different
or you meet this thing and you're like i
cannot remember what kind of shape this
is
a more general technique it's because
it's more general it's slower
but it will work no matter what kind of
shape you get perpendicular bisector or
otherwise
we're going to tackle this algebraically
now um i know
mrs lee's very purposely was avoiding
doing this
on tuesday's lesson and that's because
that's because we want you to get a
visual intuition for what's going on
that's much more powerful
than just machining through the algebra
but sometimes number one when you
don't have the visual intuition number
two when you're like oh my points are
icky
like i need to do this precisely the
algebra is the tool that you have to go
to
okay so here's what we're going to do we
want to get to a cartesian equation
that's something not in terms of zs it's
in terms of x's and y's
okay so therefore i reintroducing
rectangular form
into this equation here because it's
going to be useful to me
watch if i just do a straight
substitution right i'm going to put that
in for the first z and then i've got it
here again
x i y it's time for me to expand this
term over here okay so i have this in
here now
i've made progress i've got x's and y's
no more z's but
my cartesian equation shouldn't have
eyes flying around in it right like i
should be able to
write this in terms of just a
two-dimensional um
relationship so i somehow want to get
rid of all these eyes
flying around okay now i want you to
think back
to how we defined the modulus of z if
you have some
complex number z and it's in um
rectangular form how do you find its
modulus
do you remember we we had to use our old
friend
pythagoras right it's the square root of
yeah our our two horizontal and vertical
coordinates right so x squared plus y
squared in this case right so i can find
i can you see how this gets rid of all
of my eyes and that kind of thing this
is a cartesian relationship right
so if i can do something like this here
then i'm good to go
okay the only problem is these guys here
don't look like
they're in rectangular form i need to
twist and turn these a little bit okay
this one's not so hard watch what is the
real component
of take a breath x plus i y plus i
which part is the real part
it's just the x isn't it everything else
has an i attached to it so
that's not too hard i'll just hang that
out the front which is the
imaginary component yeah it's
it's i y plus i but normally in
rectangular form
i factorize out my eye right so
i'll stay with red factor out my eye
anyway um
what am i going to get when i take out a
factor of i i get y
plus 1 in this case right because
there's just one eye hanging out there
is that okay
so when i close this you can see
this is in rectangular form now real
part imaginary part
i could do this thing on it is that all
right
about the right hand side again help me
find the
real and the imaginary components real
first
what's real in here the x is real
and that -3 also real so therefore i'm
going to group that out the front i'll
even put brackets around it just to make
it super obvious
real component i'm going to start to
factor out the eye of the rest of it
what have i got here it's similar but
slightly different yeah
y minus one lot of i so i get this
factorization from those two terms okay
so now that i can close my modulus i'm
ready to go into this
okay but um i mean i'm going to get a
square root on this side i'm going to
get a square root on that side
gross i don't want square roots and i've
got one on both sides i might as well go
one extra step
and square both of them right do you see
what i just did
i'm about to get a square root here and
a square root here
which i need to get rid of so i might as
well take that step now
and square both sides is that okay all
right
so let's do real component squared plus
imaginary components squared
there's the real component squared
and then here comes the imaginary
component
squared so far so good what about over
here
real component squared
imaginary component squared okay
now this you see what i mean by this is
a much longer way than just if i knew
what this shape was
i could just go straight to the relevant
features midpoint
gradient this is long however
you must have some faith and i'm going
to invite you to do the algebra now
right
you must have some faith that all this
complicated stuff will eventually
marvelously cancel out maybe you're
already starting to see
the bits that are going to cancel so go
ahead and do that and then
find for me a cartesian equation if you
already got it call me over i just want
a quick look
alright so um i saw some promising signs
maybe you got there
i've just put in my immediate next line
and even though this does look like
it's going to be an unmitigated disaster
i would call it
a mitigated disaster because even though
you have a lot of terms here it's just
cancel land everywhere isn't it because
you've got these x
squared terms they're gone um you've got
these
y squared terms they're gone you even
for free
you get these plus ones because of the
symmetry of this
they're gone so therefore you end up
getting uh
i only have a two y left over here and
i've got a
just checking that i've um oh sorry i
take it back i've got a i'm going to add
2y to both sides so i get 4y
over here i might as well write that and
then i'm getting this
on the right hand side yeah you could
make this in general form or you could
divide through at this point to put it
into
slope intercept form so you might have
this as your final
line were you okay with that did you
arrive and so you're like ah no wonder
no wonder i could not simply eyeball
that because i don't really have a good
enough scale to say oh that must be nine
or four
of course right um and then your
x-intercepts will be three over two as
well
and you're fine okay does that make
sense now i got a good question from
um from manual just now about like see
see this dotted line in here
the interval between my two i call them
my um
my reference points right um do i need
to put those two in
uh sorry that that interval in the short
answer is
you put it in if it is required as part
of your working for where you got this
line from okay let me explain to you why
it would be necessary or why it wouldn't
this interval is important if i look at
this equation
and i say perpendicular bisector
therefore i'm going to start to find the
point that it goes through and the
gradient
right if you are coming from the point
of logic that this must be a
perpendicular
bisector then it rather matters to me
that the thing you are perpendicular to
and the thing you are bisecting
is on your diagram like that needs to be
there if you want to
make that argument have a look at this
this mess of working over here right
not an efficient way to go about it but
it got us the equation did i ever have
to rely
on my knowledge of it being a
perpendicular bisector at any point
doing this working
never right like this interval didn't
even come into my reasoning so therefore
if this was the way i went about it i
could just go straight to doing the line
and i would be fine because this is my
working not a geometric argument is that
okay
algebraic argument geometric argument